kill every Targaryen
my hands are everyone who isn't
so I did it bring me its panties we take
what is ours
[Music]
death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last but we all die the enemy always
wins and we still need to fight him
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video before I get started
I just want to remind everyone about the
new giveaway because I will be
announcing the first-place winner in one
week from today I am giving away the
isang of Ice and Fire book collection
and the Game of Thrones blu-ray set if
you would like to enter the giveaway
just click on the link that is down
below in the description of this video
you can enter your name several times to
increase your chances of winning so good
luck everyone now let's begin today I
want to talk about beric Dondarrion and
the Hound and why I think they still
have a big part to play in the upcoming
great war against the night king
unfortunately this is another video I am
having to make over from scratch
HBO put some more copyright claims on my
original video and I'm not able to
download it from my own channel so I
decided to make it again the last time
we saw beric Dondarrion was when the
night king attacked eastwatch-by-the-sea
barrack and tormund were atop the wall
as part of it came crashing down but
they did survive the attack if Game of
Thrones would have continued to follow
the books beric Dondarrion would have
died a few seasons ago but they continue
to keep this character alive and I
believe it's because he's going to
sacrifice his own life for the sake of
someone else's just like he did in the
books some of you might not know this
but after lady Catelyn was killed in the
books
her body was thrown into the river three
days later
Nymeria pulls her out of the water and
this is when the Brotherhood without
banners discover her corpse
beric Dondarrion ends up giving lady
Catelyn the kiss of life which passes
barracks life force into Caitlin's and
this is when she rises as Lady
Stoneheart many fans were hoping they
would do this in the show but it's way
too late for this now but Barry could
still give someone the kiss of life we
are going to see a battle for the dawn
next season and this would be the
perfect opportunity for baritone Darion
to do something like this because I
would bet someone
important characters are going to be
killed during this great battle against
the army of the dead since season 8 is
the last season we are going to see a
lot of characters die and beric
Dondarrion will most likely be one of
them considering he has already lived
longer than his character was meant to
barracks character in the books was
designed for a few different reasons one
of those reasons is to introduce the
possibility of someone being brought
back from the dead
and his other purpose is to bring
someone back from the dead himself and I
still believe he can fulfill this
purpose in this show even though he
won't be doing it with the same
character from the books I know some
people were thinking beric was going to
bring John back from the dead during
their mission beyond the wall but as we
all know that never happened
I tend to believe they are waiting to
reveal barracks full powers in the last
season if they are going to kill off
this character you might as well let him
go out in style and I think they could
do this by having Barry give the kiss of
life to Sandor Clegane now I don't have
a ton of evidence to back this up but I
think this could work because these two
characters have been linked to each
other for quite some time in fact
beric Dondarrion has had a connection to
the claw gains ever since season one and
book 1 all the way back in season 1 Ned
Stark enlisted beric Dondarrion to
deliver the Kings justice to the
mountain at the time beric Dondarrion
was played by a different actor but this
was when the mountain was terrorizing
any village in his path Lord beric
Dondarrion
you shall have the command assemble 100
men who rides a cigarette Gorsky as you
come on barrack does eventually find him
but he is killed and this is one of the
times Thoris of Mir has to bring him
back then you fast forward to season 3
and beric Dondarrion crosses paths with
another Clegane and this is when the
Hound is sentenced to a trial by combat
for killing the butcher's boy
beric Dondarrion volunteers to face the
hound and once again he is killed by
another Clegane now I know what some of
you may be thinking why the hell would
barrack want to save a Clegane when they
are the ones who are constantly killing
him well I think it is interesting that
barracks story has been intertwined with
the Cole gain ever since the first
season and book in the television show
barrack isn't introduced until Ned Stark
sends him out to find the mountain and I
think it would actually be kind of
poetic if Barret gave his life to save
the Hound and then the Hound went and
killed his brother in a weird roundabout
way berrak would still be helping kill
the mountain and those were the orders
Ned Stark gave him back in season 1
berrak did tell the Hound that the cold
winds were rising in the north and he
knew the Hound had a part to play in
this great war which is one of the
reasons why they wanted the Hound to
join them in the first place do you want
to join us we can use you
I tried joining didn't work out for me
claim we hey Louise
the Lord of Light is keeping the barrack
alive for a reason he gave a failed
drunk priest the power to bring him back
true reason we are part of something
larger than ourselves well the time has
come for the Hound to play his part he
saw the visions in the flames and he
knows they need him in order to help end
the darkness berrak also knows that the
Hound is a much better fighter than he
is berrak had to learn this the hard way
after he challenged him during the trial
by combat so he knows they need the
Hound more than they need him now I
would hate to draw a line in the sand
between these two great characters but
if I can only have one fighting beside
me it would be the Hound if the Hound
would happen to be mortally wounded
during this upcoming battle for the dawn
then I think beric would save him
knowing he could do a lot more damage
against the dead not only that but beric
knows that the Lord of Light is keeping
the Hound around for a reason there has
to be some kind of power or force that
is keeping him alive because he should
have died a long time ago maybe it's the
old gods well maybe it's the Lord of
Light or maybe they're all the same
[ __ ] thing I don't know what matters
I believe is that there's something
greater than us and whatever it is it's
got plans for Sandor Clegane
plus everyone keeps telling the hound
that he has a part to play and the Lord
isn't done with him yet so he needs to
be around for something big
berrak also knows that him and the Hound
are meant to meet again this was the
very last thing he said to him before
they parted ways we'll meet again -
again maybe he already knows what he has
to do which could be another reason why
he said they would meet again next
season
I think the Hound is slowly starting to
see that he has a big part to play but
he doesn't fully understand what it
means The Hound might act like an
[ __ ] around beric but he does have
some respect for him but even beric
Dondarrion doesn't fully understand why
he keeps being brought back to life by
the Lord of Light this was another
interesting scene with merrick and hound
and I think they may have even ended
this scene as a bit of foreshadowing as
to why beric is still alive I've met
better men than you and they've been
hanging from crossbeams beheaded I'll
just shut themselves to death in a field
somewhere none of them came back so why
you you think I don't ask myself that
every hour of every day why am I here as
you can see neither one of them seem to
know why Barret keeps being brought back
from the dead The Hound even thinks it's
kind of ridiculous that Barret would be
brought back when he knows there are
much better men who deserve to still be
alive but would it not be kind of ironic
if barrack was still around in the show
to keep the Hound alive now I know
barracks character did not do this in
the books but the television show is
obviously making their own version of
the story and I think they have new
plans for beric Dondarrion and the Hound
they must be keeping these two
characters together for a reason and I
think it's because barrack will
eventually give the Hound the kiss of
life then after the Hound is brought
back to life he will get his revenge on
his brother Gregor Clegane and like I
said earlier if barrack did this he
would still be serving Ned Stark's
justice in a roundabout way Ned Stark
wanted the mountain to pay for his
crimes but barrack was not able to kill
him but if he saved the Hound
then the Hound went and killed his
brother berrak would still be playing a
part in his downfall I think this would
be an interesting way to do this because
he could wrap up a few different story
lines but let me know what you think
about this put all your thoughts down in
the comment section also don't forget
about the giveaway the first-place
winner will be announced in one week
then the second-place winner will be
announced a few days after that if you
would like to enter just use the links
that are down below anyways I want to
thank you all for watching the video I
really appreciate that and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support my channel I hope
you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you